Salut tout le monde, j'ai trouvé un nouvel appart
et pour vous montrer
comment se passe un bon déménagement,
je me suis dit: "Pourquoi pas filmer?"
Il y a Akamz qui est là, en direct.
Ça va, Akamz?
Ça roule!
Le mieux, les gars, c'est de démonter vos meubles.
Ça prend moins de place.
C'est logique, c'est la base d'un déménagement.
D'ailleurs, Riadh,
tu peux aller démonter la chaise, là-bas?
Qu'est-ce que tu me racontes?
Démonter les chaises, c'est un malade lui.
Vas-y, vas-y.
Trust me, trust me.
Allô?
Bonjour, Anthony, votre conseiller EDF.
je vous confirme la souscription
de votre contrat d'énergie
pour votre nouvel appartement.
Est-ce que je peux vous être utile
pour autre chose?
Pour l'instant, je pense qu'on n'en a pas besoin,
mais merci quand même, Monsieur.
Parfait.
Sinon, vous avez toujours la checklist sur Check,
l'assistant de déménagement d'EDF
qui vous permet de penser à relever le compteur,
à souscrire à l'assurance habitation, etc.
Ah oui, c'est vrai,
l'assurance habitation et le compteur.
J'avais zappé.
Écoutez ce qu'on va faire,
j'ai votre numéro, si j'ai besoin, je vous rappelle.
Merci beaucoup, Monsieur, merci.
Les gars, petite astuce.
Pour les vêtements, utilisez des sacs poubelle.
C'est plus solide et c'est réutilisable.
Vous ouvrez ça,
vous foutez les vêtements à l'intérieur
et gardez les cartons
pour les trucs lourds et fragiles.
Ça, c'est fait.
On passe à la suite.
La checklist…
Akamz!
- Ouais?
- Tu devais ramener des cartons?
Je les ai laissés dans la cour, au cas où!
Au cas où quoi?
La table, elle est encore là
et tu as oublié les cartons?
Elle est entièrement démontée, la table.
Il faut la ranger !
Va ramener des cartons, s'il te plaît.
OK, OK, calme-toi.
Il est là pour m'aider ou pas lui ?
Les gars, vous vous souvenez des cartons?
Regardez ce qu'il a fait.
Regardez bien, regardez.
C'est bon, regarde, ça passe.
De quoi, ça passe? Regarde.
Tiens mon portefeuille,
va au supermarché et regarde s'ils ont des cartons
et tu prends un truc à manger au passage.
Waouh!
Là, tu me parles!
Ça va être long, cette journée.
Toujours faire attention, les objets de valeur,
il faut les protéger.
Ultra fragile, on est bien !
Ils n'ont plus de cartons.
C'est un déménagement ou c'est un cauchemar?
C'est galère.
Tu as pris quoi?
Pizza.
Pizza, mais on n'a pas de four.
Tu as un micro-ondes?
Bon, je vais appeler le mec, là.
Allô?
Oui, c'est le gars du déménagement.
On s'est appelés tout à l'heure.
Oui, Monsieur Belaïche, tout va bien?
Non, il n'y a rien qui va.
Les cartons, ils sont trempés,
on les a laissés dans la cour.
On est en galère, on n'a pas de cartons.
Je peux vous en faire livrer, si vous voulez.
Comme vous êtes client EDF,
vous avez même des réductions sur les cartons.
Ah bon, c'est possible ? On peut faire ça?
Il vous en faut combien?
Franchement, ça passe.Regarde ça.
Je suis au téléphone, laisse-moi.
Les gars, c'est comment?
Regardez, j'ai trouvé quoi: les cartons.
Ils sont là, les cartons!
Alors, j'ai géré ou je n'ai pas géré?
- Super, super!
- Tu es en train de manger?
Assieds-toi!
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on a au menu?
Je ne vais pas manger cette pizza.
Elle est éclatée, frère.
Attends, attends, attends!
Tu veux que je mange quoi?
Mais quoi? Ça passe!
Mange ta pizza et après, on va faire les cartons.
Mais moi, je ne mange pas ta pizza.
Riadh,
Riadh, qu'est-ce qui se passe,
tu fais un AVC ou quoi?
J'ai un mauvais pressentiment
pour le camion de demain.
Pourquoi? Boris, il est là, tu le connais.
Je le connais, c'est ça le problème.
Ah ben, on va s'adapter.